[Applaudissements]
elle est une institution en russie est
une pionnière pour le monde entier avant
d'être député à la douma et une grande
grande fidèle du président valentina
terechkova était co soit nous la toute
première femme à s'envoler dans l'espace
aujourd'hui elle pourrait très bien
s'inscrire dans l'histoire à nouveau
comme celle qui a ouvert la porte à un
règne qui assied ternel de vladimir
poutine comme président
l'amendement elle a proposé la
constitution n'était pas inscrit au
calendrier de la douma vladimir poutine
a sollicité deux autres mandats ce qui
lui permettrait de rester au pouvoir
jusqu'en 2036 un coup bien monté sur
mesure
nourri par une foule d'applaudissements
est suivie d'une visite surprise du
président lui-même qui sans hésitation
c'est du tout vert à la proposition à
condition dit-il que la cour
constitutionnelle donne son feu vert
mais ce sont vous les russes qui auront
le dernier mot a ajouté le président car
l'amendement constitutionnel sera parmi
ceux qui seront soumis un grand
référendum populaire le 22 avril
prochain il pourra sûrement compter sur
l'appui d'une bonne partie de la
population pour plus tard
je crois comme cette femme qui voit en
lui un politicien encore solide et
efficace
un sondage mené en janvier y dévoilait
d'ailleurs que 45% des russes voterait
pour lui à nouveau contre 44 qui veulent
le voir partir pour de bon en 2020 en
guerre comme milo cela qui parle de la
fatigue s'est installée et surtout de la
confusion qu'ils s'aiment chez
l'électorat avec tous les changements
propose dans son discours à la douma
poutine a répété qui est contre la
notion de président à vie bousculés pour
la stabilité du pays
en évoquant même le grand chaos qui
régnait en russie après la chute de
l'union soviétique
von heureux
quoi qu'il arrive casimir poutine est en
train de jeter les bases légales pour
maintenir une influence quasi absolu sur
la russie pour les prochaines décennies
que ce soit à titre de président ou pas
car parmi les amendements qui seront
soumis au vote le 22 avril prochain
plusieurs lui donnerait énormément de
marge de manoeuvre peut-être même des
postes clés pour s'assurer qu'il reste
l'homme de la situation bien après 2024
et si camara alter escaut radio-canada
moscou